foreign
[Music]
we are pleased to be able to provide you
with exciting news on Christmas Eve as
well our Christmas episode revolves
around a Warhammer 40K adaptation ashes
and Pikachu's Pokemon exit the prospect
of a Black Adam Sequel and a film
adaptation of the horror game Five
Nights at Freddy's in addition Avatar 3
is rumored to be over 9 hours long and
Sony is planning to bring one of the
weirdest villains ever to the big screen
have fun watching
the Pokemon franchise has had an impact
on entire Generations some grew up at
the anime from 1997 which is still
running today while others were
introduced to it by the popular Game Boy
games trading cards or Pokemon go but
there is one thing that most people
agree on the franchise is Iconic and
will continue to inspire children and
adults in the future at least for the 25
year old anime series however there will
now be a significant change according to
current reports the main series will
have to get by without its protagonist
Ash and his faithful companion Pikachu
in the future this is due to the fact
that Ash Ketchum has finally become the
Pokemon world champion and has thus
achieved his lifelong dream after so
many years on screen their farewell will
be duly commemorated with an 11 part
mini-series aimed to be a Pokemon Master
which will be released in Japan in just
a few weeks it is also already known who
will follow in the immense footsteps of
Ash and Pikachu namely two new
characters they are named Rico and Roy
and come from the paldia region Pikachu
will also be replaced by the Pokemon
spiritu fukoko and quaxley since not
much is really known about the newcomers
there are a lot of rumors one of the
most prominent speculations suggests
that the two will be Ash's children we
won't have to wait too long for the
first season with the new characters
season 26 starts in April so
speculations will certainly keep going
until then what's your theory on Riku
and Roy could they really be Ash's
children or have you got your own ideas
feel free to tell us in the comments
after an extensive promotional tour
Black Adam hit theaters on October 21
2022 the hype was huge which was mainly
due to the smart marketing of DC and
Dwayne Johnson yet it is considered safe
to say that a sequel is no longer in the
works the reason is not so much the
devastating reviews or the lack of
ticket sales but a general restructuring
of the dceu under the creative direction
of James Gunn and Peter Safran almost
all of the planned movies and sequels
that Were Somehow connected to the
so-called snyderverse or the old DC EU
have been canceled instead DC plans a
turning point as Dwayne Johnson
confirmed for the first time a few days
ago Black Adam 2 will therefore not be
released in the near future not in the
first chapter of the new DC Universe at
least this doesn't sound like a complete
farewell like that of Henry Cavill as
Superman for example nevertheless at
least for the time being we won't get to
see anything more of Black Adam the new
developments at DC are a slap in the
face a especially for Dwayne Johnson
since the 50 year old has been
advocating for a Black Adam movie for
years and was also one of the key people
behind the temporarily projected return
of Henry Cavill thus Johnson's statement
that Black Adam will play no role in the
next chapter of DC only could also be
some kind of self-therapy after hitting
the Rocks but from a financial point of
view a Black Adam too would hardly be
attractive we are all the more
interested in seeing the future of the
new dceu
it's been a turbulent few weeks for
actor Henry Cavill first he announced
his withdrawal from The Witcher series
at Netflix in order to presumably get
more involved with DC then came the
sudden end of the Superman and a Man of
Steel 2 was off the table in no time the
reason given was a restructuring of the
DC Universe for which there are
completely new plans under James Gunn
and Peter Safran now Cabell announced
the switch to an Amazon project that
should appeal to many fans it's for a
series for the Warhammer 40K Universe
the tabletop game from Games Workshop is
set in a dystopia where humans and many
other factions fight to be the dominant
species in the universe time-wise the
game is set in the far future in the
41st Millennium after Christ besides
lavish novels there are many adaptations
in the world of video games and a sci-fi
thriller titled ultramarines has also
been released however there are no real
series yet that will now change under
the leadership of Amazon more specific
details about the plot or cavill's role
are not known however according to his
own statement the 39 year old has been a
big fan of the Warhammer 40K franchise
for years and is said to have actively
helped Amazon secure the corresponding
rights as a producer a series about The
Inquisitor Gregor eisenhorn was already
planned a while ago whether the current
announcement is also about the series we
do not know due to the fact that the
world is gigantic speculations about the
plot are very difficult cities are in
part as large as entire continents and
spaceships are also oversized in
addition the vast expanses of space are
waiting to be explored in all directions
despite the lack of details about the
plot a lot of fans are optimistic about
the series project Cabell is considered
a hardliner in terms of story templates
as he already proved with The Witcher
which earned him a lot of Praise from
like-minded fans what the exact schedule
of the Warhammer 40K project looks like
is currently only known by those
responsible in Cavill himself
nevertheless there are Ambitions to
create a complete universe and not
solely a series in any case there is
plenty of story material in the 35 year
old game
James Cameron's Avatar 2 the way of
water is currently playing in cinemas
and is working hard to earn back the
insanely high production costs and meet
the high expectations with 435 million
dollars worldwide the movie is in third
place for the best opening weekend since
the pandemic both doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness and Spider-Man no
way home were able to outperform James
Cameron's Mega project behind the scenes
there is little time to rest despite the
theatrical release on December 16th
after all there are still three films to
go before Cameron's vision is fully
brought to the big screen as producer
John Landau confirmed Avatar 3 is
already 95 complete after the scripts
for all five parts have been known
internally for some time anyway
currently they are busy shooting Avatar
4 which like Parts 2 and 3 is supposed
to introduce both a new culture and new
tribes the current version of Avatar 3
is said to be a full nine hours long and
is packed with special effects from the
first minute to the last that doesn't
mean that the final version will also be
9 hours long however according to
Hollywood Insider Jeff Snyder James
Cameron is said to have explicitly
demanded that all scenes shot must be in
top quality so that he could choose at a
high standard this is quite unusual
since most Productions edit based on Raw
versions of the scenes not only is it
less expensive it's also less time
consuming for the perfectionist Cameron
and his life's work Avatar however this
is probably out of the question if one
is to believe Snyder's rumors the future
of the movie series now depends solely
on the box office results of Avatar the
way of water and Avatar 3. if both
movies only perform moderately a
continuation of the cost intensive
franchise is unlikely in Disney would
have to put a stop to Cameron's passion
project
it's not just the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that is constantly growing and
can fall back on an Ever larger catalog
of movies and series the Sony Spider-Man
universe is also striving to further
develop various projects as The
Hollywood Reporter informed this week
next to El muerto and Madame Webb
another spin-off of Spider-Man is in the
pipeline it's about Hypno Hustler who as
his name suggests is a fairly weird
character the villain's real name is
Antoine Del soy and he is the front man
of the band Mercy Killers whose
instruments are equipped with the
ability of hypnosis with this he can put
his audience in a trance and then Rob
them at this point it's probably not
surprising to anyone that Sony hasn't
focused on the bizarre character so far
and that's why he hasn't been featured
in movies and series until now at least
in fact there is already a well-known
actor who will take on the role in the
spin-off namely Donald Glover a 39 year
old multi-talented actor is also a
five-time Grammy award winner under his
stage name Childish Gambino so we can
easily imagine him in the role of the
crazy Hypno Hustler nothing is known
about the plot of the spin-off yet but
we are eager to see how the setting will
be realized after all Hypno Hustler made
its debut at the end of the 70s and thus
in the middle of the worldwide disco era
due to the involvement of Donald Glover
however a more modern hip-hop setting is
just as feasible either way we are very
excited about it a release date has not
been set yet
a movie for the upcoming adaptation of
the multi-part horror game Five Nights
at Freddy's has been in planning for
quite some time apart from the
announcement that plumhouse will produce
the film there has been little
information so far well that changed
this week when the signing of the First
cast members was announced so far scream
actor Matthew Lillard and Josh
Hutcherson who played the character Pita
malark and The Hunger Games have joined
the cast Hutcherson will play the main
role of security guard Mike Schmidt
while Lillard will star as the
antagonist also cast is newcomer Piper
Rubio who will play Mike's sister
Gathering behind the camera are Emma
Tammy who steps in for the Harry Potter
director Chris Columbus who was
originally slated to direct and Five
Nights at Freddy's Creator Seth
Cuddeback and Scott cawthorne who are
working with Tammy on the script the
Five Nights at Freddy's video games are
about a gradually unfolding backstory
which at times is not told
chronologically the big antagonist is
the inventor William Afton who created
highly Advanced animatronics for his
company Fazbear their entertainment
these were actually intended for
entertaining children in restaurants as
it later turns out there is much more
behind the characters than just harmless
fun as security guard Mike Will very
quickly discover during his shifts in
the world of gaming Five Nights at
Freddy's is a well-established franchise
with nine games in its main series it is
not known whether the entire storyline
will be adapted into a movie straight
away or whether the one or other option
might be left open in case of success
the shooting of the film is scheduled to
start in a few months
that's it for this week's news if you
want to keep fueling your excitement for
the upcoming movie season alongside all
the holiday hustle and bustle we've got
another present for you in our new
original we're sharing everything you
need to know about Marvel's ironheart
and feel free to let us know in the
comments which upcoming movies and
series you cannot wait to see please
enjoy the next few days Merry Christmas
everyone
foreign
[Music]